Devil Facial Tumour Disease is one of the
most unique
and unusual diseases in the world
because it is a transmissible cancer,
and to our knowledge there are only two
cases, in biology
of these transmissible cancers, one is in the dogs and the other one is in the devils.
Canine Transmissible Venereal Tumour, as its name suggests,
is a sexually transmitted cancer and it leads to the appearance of tumours
on the external genitalia of both male and
female dogs.
Both the Canine Transmissible Venereal Tumour and the Tasmanian Devil Facial Tumour Disease
are transmissible cancers spread by the transfer of living cancer cells.
The canine tumour is very treatable, it's actually very responsive
to certain types of chemotherapy treatment
and actually almost all cases can be
cured within a few weeks through this course of chemotherapy.
We're very interested in understanding why it is that chemotherapy is so successful
with treating the canine cancer, whereas
it's been tried
with the Tasmanian devil cancer and it's not
very successful at all.